for example let's just if you know my
role playing
if you came to me and you saw me on the
bridge what would be the first thing you
would ask me
so here's what i would do let's say
you are over the rail standing on this
eye beam if that's that's over there
instead of me just walking up to you and
start to talk i'm going to stay about 10
15 feet back
and i'm just gonna open hand and go you
can see i'm in uniform i'm somebody of
authority just go hey
i'm kevin is it okay if i come up and
chat with you for a while
and when you allow me to boom that
that's a great icebreaker right there
i'm giving you the opportunity
to allow me to come up because many many
times these folks have been kicked down
so often and told no no no you need to
do this you should have done that
by me asking a question is it okay if i
come up
and speak with you i think that sets it
for a really good tone
for that interaction and when you do i'm
gonna explain it i'm kevin briggs with
the patrol
i'm here for you today what's been going
on
i'm not gonna touch you i'm not gonna
grab you and we've all seen it
where an officer or a citizen rushes up
on a building or onto a bridge or
something and grabs someone and pulls
them over fantastic great
but i want to go deeper i want that
individual to come back
over that rail on their own because
imagine the courage that it takes to go
over that rail to begin with
now think and imagine the courage that
it takes
to come back over that rail yeah so if
you have the courage to come back over
the rail you have the courage to fight
and continue on
and that's my thought process on that
and and has it ever happened where
you've gone up and you have
started a conversation they didn't
listen to and they jumped off has that
happened right in front of you
yes yes unfortunately yes
how come they just want some time to to
really
get it into their head and yeah
anybody ever makes it i remember i saw
one story where one gentleman made it
did you ever have any stories of people
making it or no
yes um i did have a guy that made it but
i was not there when he jumped i was
actually busy with another
case so i met him in the hospital so
they're
they're very very few and usually if
they do make it
they have substantial injuries also when
when you're there
and and and those who jumped
what was the tipping point that got them
to jump like what did
i'm sure there's a commonality amongst
those who jump and then after they jump
do you see a reaction from them the
moment they let go
usually when they let go
um my heart breaks i start tearing up a
lot of times
it it just messes you up you know it's
horrible when you're there
so what i teach folks now for
negotiators is not to look
because that fall that's what's going to
be in your head so i
when i talk to negotiators and those who
do this type of work
i tell them if it's inevitable or that
person all of a sudden leaps on you
don't look down and watch that body oh
my gosh wow i did
i did the times when i worked because i
wanted to watch i want will really not
watch but mark
that body because it's so treacherous
down there with the currents
so we we have markers that we throw and
all that but that's what's in my head
not talking to that individual but that
jump and that hit
and that's what's going to mess people
up later on down the line
you know you see a lot as as an officer
and paramedics and things
that's in your head and we all need to
be able to continue to work and do the
work that we want to do
so if you like this sort of short clip
from an interview i did click over here
to watch the entire
interview and please don't forget to
subscribe to the channel
take care everybody bye
[Music]
you